le sarnez merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur france bleu 107 1 françois
hollande peut-il annoncé des mesures
pour mieux vivre ensemble en france
c'est ce matin sa conférence de presse
il est dans un contexte favorable ça
fait longtemps que celles n'y est pas
arrivé presque depuis son élection hier
sa cote de popularité c'est le fait
qu'il est noir histoire dans la presse à
gauche il retrouve vois bien une
certaine fierté de leur président donc
il ya une évolution qui est favorable
les astres sont avec lui on peut dire
moi je pense vraiment que il doit se
servir de ce moment là pour mener
proposer une vision une perspective pour
le pays que s'il ne le fait pas dans ce
contexte là qui est favorable mais il ne
le fera jamais donc j'attends de lui
qu'il trace des perspectives matière
d'emploi en matière d'éducation des
perspectives pour la nation mais les a
déjà tenu les a déjà fait ses
perspectives le dis très souvent il a
une ligne et il ne va pas en bouger ne
va pas changer politiciens quand tout
allait bien en france ça se verrait et
ça se saurait moi je crois qu'on a
besoin de faire des réformes très
importantes je crois qu'on a besoin de
soutenir beaucoup plus qu'on ne le fait
aujourd'hui tout ce qui est création
d'emplois tous les productions déchets
c'est très important je crois qu'on a
besoin d'avoir une école qui soit un
meilleur niveau quand vous regardez les
classements pisa année après année
l'école de france dégringole on est
incapable d'apprendre à lire à écrire
à tous nos enfants c'est tout de même
une difficulté majeure donc nous avons
des chantiers très important peut-être
la politique de la ville dont on va
parler ensemble ou à mon avis il faut
vraiment changer de braquet justes noces
à la priorité ce matin c'est quoi pour
vous vous avez en évidence si vous si
vous me dites ça va être le thème de sa
conférence de presse le vivre ensemble
service civique lors duquel il a
beaucoup consulté les élus de banlieue
par exemple le vivre ensemble ça passe
d'abord par une école qui fait son
travail auprès de tous les enfants de la
république qui fasse que puis y est plus
un enfant qui passe en sixième sans
maîtriser la lecture et l'écriture parce
qu'après il est évidemment perdu et on
peut c'est très difficile d'agir etc
aussi des emplois qu'on doit delà de la
production de richesse qu'on doit
recréer en france et donc pour ça il ya
ça tombe de réformes à faire
d'assouplissement à conduire
d'assouplissement du code du travail
d'assouplissement das atteignant 2
heures école de centrer sur ce qui est
important sur l'école la gauche embauche
de nouveaux
est-ce que c'est ce qu'il savait non
c'est vraiment pas suffisant et c'est
vraiment pas fait le bon diagnostic
si on pense que ce sont les moyens qui
font la qualité de l'école ben vous vous
apercevez aujourd'hui de l'échec de tout
cela on a moins de personnel dans
l'éducation nationale non il ya une
semaine en conséquence c'est pas vrai je
dis très franchement c'est un budget
qu'on devrait sanctuarisées à la limite
mais enfin on n'a pas besoin de
continuer à embaucher on peut refaire
une répartition à l'intérieur il faut
avoir de meilleur encadrement et
peut-être des plus petits groupes dans
le primaire et on peut ensuite quand
vous avez une plus grande homogénéité
que vous arrivez au collège et au lycée
ensuite regarder les choses différemment
donc je crois pas du tout ça soit liée
aux moyens je crois que c'est lié à ce
qui se passe dans la classe d'abord
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
parlez à un enseignant et vous explique
que 90 % de son temps de leur qu'il
donne ben c'est affaire a essayé et
vaguement de restaurer une autorité sur
des élèves qui n'en veulent pas et puis
il va faire court pendant cinq ou dix
minutes vous dites on voit comme ce
matin là j'ai dû faire pousser leur
retour de l'uniforme chantaient la
marseillaise je crois pas du tout que
les arguments d'autorité quels qu'ils
soient fonctionne je crois que l'école
c'est d'abord l'apprentissage de la de
la conscience d'une certaine
responsabilité de la compréhension du
monde et c'est pour ça que je crois mais
fondamental essentiel vital que tous les
enfants de france apprennent à lire à
écrire à maîtriser à maîtriser le sens
de ce qu'ils disent ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui 40% riz dans sixième sens de
maîtriser et le mot apartheid puisque il
devrait être question de la politique de
la ville ce matin dans la conférence de
presse de françois hollande le mot
apartheid commencer par manuel valls est
il juste à vos yeux moi j'aurais
peut-être pas employer le même mot mais
j'ai pas envie de polémiquer parce qu'en
fait et ce qu'ils viennent fracture oui
est ce qu'il y a même fracture qui s'est
aggravée depuis des décennies la réponse
est oui vous voyez bien qu'il ya tout le
monde n'a pas les mêmes chances dans la
vie que le niveau de chômage n'est pas
le même selon que vous êtes au coeur
d'une ville où selon que vous vivez dans
une banlieue que évidemment il ya une
ghettoïsation qu'il ya une facture très
lourde je pense que ça doit nous aussi
qu'on doit regarder la question de la
politique de la ville je crois qu'on a
depuis 30 ans une politique de la ville
avec beaucoup beaucoup des dizaines de
milliards qui ont été dépensés des
choses qui ont été faites bien sûr en
matière de construction je pense à
l'anru par exemple mais au fond je crois
qu'il faut changer de braquet la
politique de la ville c'est la même
chose que ce que j'ai dit au fond on
devrait se concentrer sur sur deux
piliers le premier pilier qu'est celui
de l'école comme à faire en sorte
d'apprendre à tous et le deuxième pilier
c'est celui de l'emploi donné de
l'emploi quand vous allez dans les
banlieues c'est frappant de voir
l'énergie qui lie à la créativité qui
lie h et des jeunes qui sont obligés au
fait de se débrouiller par eux-mêmes
parce que l'état n'est pas là parce que
le tissu associatif
facile donc on a une créativité
formidable donc il faut favoriser la
création d'emplois il faut peut-être
amplifier les zones franches il faut
faire en sorte de se servir de toute
cette énergie là au service de l'emploi
et est-ce qu'il faut lutter aussi contre
le front national
est ce que vous faites partie de cette
tendance pour le front républicain par
exemple pour la législative moi je serai
dans les âmes et faudrait les choses
simplement un dans une élection il ya
deux tours au premier tour on choisit
qui a sa préférence puis au deuxième
tour on élimine c'est comme ça continue
donc l'ump est éliminé donc moi je faut
faire barrage au candidat du front
national pas de nier c'est d'ailleurs ce
que nous avons dit avec françois bayrou
c'est d'ailleurs chez nous une position
constante pas besoin de nous réunir
pendant deux jours ou trois jours cela
fait plusieurs années que nous sommes
exactement sur la même position quand
jean marie le candice magie de valeur on
touche à l'essentiel quand jean marie le
pen dit ce matin le front républicain
c'est l'ump res qui défend sa gamelle je
ne sais pas si c'est le front
républicain mais en tous les cas au
deuxième tour vous choisissez de mettre
de côté ou de fans de barrage à celui
qui vous semble au fond
le plus mettant en cause de plus
profondément les valeurs de ce que nous
sommes ensemble et notre république
c'est exactement ça notre position vous
auriez voter ps et dont j'aurais voté
pour monsieur barbier marielle de sarnez
l'invité politique de france bleu 107 1
jusqu'à 20h45 la suite dans quelques
secondes après la météo et le trafic le
temps pour aujourd'hui et froid ce matin
la température négative quasiment
partout il fait 0 - 1 degré à paris - 1°
également à trappes -1° également plus
au sud du côté de sommer vous le voyez
ce sera commis hier un beau ciel bleu
tout au long de la journée et pas plus
de quatre à paris pour cet après-midi la
qualité de l'air sur une échelle qui va
de un très bon madrid 10 très mauvais et
bien c'est du quatre aujourd'hui sur la
route maintenant laurent a quelque chose
à nous dire bonjour laurent
ok merci pour cette info
et autres pannes et autres accidents ont
été dégagés
marielle de sarnez est l'invité
politique de france bleu 107 1 ce matin
un programme télé à choisir pour ce soir
si vous êtes devant votre télé vous êtes
plutôt devant envoyé spécial sur france
2 ou bien pretty woman c'est w9
se compter car j'ai déjà vu mais c'est
bon quand même c'est pour ça que je vous
propose il est pas mal de
choses ici chose d'aussi guen c'est
sympa moi je les ai vus plusieurs fois
déjà alors poitiers wons moman
robin dame ce crime
et en main
alors
que
et s'il fallait choisir une sortie dans
paris ce soir à l'olympia il ya
véronique sanson et au palais des sports
il ya la comédie musicale dirty dancing
harmonix en son nom du gras sans hésiter
oui sans hésiter
m
le to qui va
m oh
ce soir encore et ça marche bien puisque
l'olympia et complet pour accueillir
véronique sanson
et retour à la politique marielle de
sarnez sur france bleu 107 1 avec nos
idées sylvain quelques secondes une
question sur la mobilité et la
circulation à paris avec le plan dany
d'algues ou anti pollution mais vous
êtes députée européenne marielle de
sarnez sur l'europe que comprenez vous à
cette signification à ce vote pour
syriza en grèce 11 est un vote qui
repose sur de nombreuses raisons si on
veut aller très très vite les cas qu'ils
ont dit non à cette austérité qui
connaissent depuis cinq ans et des
coupes dans les salaires absolument
drastique et une augmentation des impôts
des taxes auxquelles vous ne pouvez tout
simplement pas faire face et puis ils
ont dit non si on dit pas assez à la
gestion de leur classe politique depuis
depuis vingt autres escales sur droite
et gauche confondues droite et gauche
confondues vous savez que c'est une
gestion politique très familiale en
grèce et au fonds on voit bien que les
hommes politiques ont tapé sur l'europe
oui mais ça c'est toujours très très
simple d'avoir le bouc émissaire alors
si vous me dites est ce qu'ils n'ont pas
dit non un peu aussi à la tre k je vous
dis oui bien sûr ils ont dit non à cette
fameuse troïka qui est devenu tellement
fameuse mais qui était pour moi mais je
le dis depuis le début c'était pas la
bonne solution déjà c'est pas la bonne
solution de la place à une troïka c'est
pas la bonne solution que ce soit
anonyme que ce soit des fonctionnaires
des technocrates qui débarquent tous
ceux ci sont reclus que j'avais un gala
mercal merci tout ceci savait pas une
bonne chose oui m'enfin il faut qu'il
retienne aussi qu'a eue la solidarité de
l'europe avec eux moi je suis
profondément européenne parce que
justement je considère qu'on fait partie
d'une même famille mais vous avez député
européen dans les uns ou les autres ont
des difficultés se serrer les coudes et
donc les grecs ils ont évidemment
bénéficier de la solidarité européenne
ils vont continuer d'en bénéficier
simplement il ya un point très important
qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis cinq ans
je voulais dit on à couper dans les
salaires on augmente les impôts et les
taxes mais on n'a pas fait les réformes
on n'a fait aucune des réformes
structurelles dont la grèce a pu
tellement besoin vous savez qui par
exemple ne les a pas de cadastre ya pas
de cadastre en grèce y'a pas de cadastre
le prélèvement des impôts il est on va
dire aléatoire l'évasion fiscale elle
est considérable ce qu'on appelle les
oligarques et ses bas il échappe à
l'impôt la question de l'église
orthodoxe la question des armateurs
finalement vous voyez d'un bon oeil
syriza parce que ses réserves à remettre
de l'ordre dans tout ça écoutez syriza
il a une voie étroite parce qu'il a
beaucoup promis et il a promis des
choses qui ne seront pas tenable et donc
moi je fais plutôt partie des gens qui
aiment quand on dit des choses en
campagne qui sont ensuite tenus ce qui
d'ailleurs en france aussi n'existe pas
reims assez classique des hommes
politiques voire mais ces gens qui
commencent à revenir sur ces sur la
plupart ses promesses il a dit on va re
nationaliser ce qu on a privatisé ben il
a renoncé par exemple à renationaliser
une partie du pirée parce que ça coûte
très très cher que vous entendre députée
européenne vous dites il faut raser sa
dette la supprimer non non non je savais
que la dette c'est ce que vous avez
peut-être un peu sur votre compte en
banque c'est ce que tous les auditeurs
qui nous écoutent s'ils ont un tout
petit peu d'argent c'est cet argent qui
sait aussi qui a aidé les grecs donc
nous avons nous plus de 40 milliards en
france donc c'est pas une dette comme ça
hors sol donc évidemment qu'il faut
qu'ils tiennent leurs engagements après
ce qu on peut renégocier dans la durée
oui est ce qu'on peut lier les
remboursements à une partie une partie
des remboursements à leur pib la réponse
est oui est ce qu'on peut faire baisser
les taux d'intérêts la réponse est oui à
partir du moment où ils tiennent leurs
engagements à partir du moment où ils
disent voilà les réformes que nous vous
proposons de mettre en oeuvre et à ce
moment là il peut y avoir un nouveau
pack de confiance elle ne servait êtres
conseillère de paris la question
mobilité le plan d'anne hidalgo anti
pollution est il inévitable à paris tout
le monde est d'accord pour lutter contre
la pollution elle aurait pu le faire
depuis 13 ans un jeu je dis ça en
passant nous nous le demandons depuis
très longtemps
je suis d'accord sur l'objectif je suis
pas du tout d'accord sur la méthode je
suis pas d'accord sur la méthode
interdiction dès le 1er juillet d'abord
on intervient tôt que d'inciter et moi
je trouve que on est dans un monde où
déjà la vie est assez compliqué pour
l'instant la mairie de paris nadal
incité depuis 2001 et en réduisant les
voies pour les voitures n'ont pas
suffisamment et donc on pourrait inciter
deuxièmement ça veut dire quoi au 1er
juillet ça veut dire que le poids lourd
qui polluent vraiment ok il leur a plu
aura de venir il valait ou en banlieue
donc en banlieue on aura le droit de
continuer à avoir des bus des cars de
tourisme des poids lourds qui vont
polluer et bien écoutez est ce que tout
ceci est républicain est ce que tout
ceci est égalitaire je ne le crois pas
et donc je crois que la manière de faire
ne convient pas je pense qu'il faut
d'abord laisser du temps pour trouver
des alternatives
je pense qu'il faut le faire avec les
communes avoisinantes et au minimum il
aurait fallu le faire au sein de la
métropole pour que ça ait un sens donc
nous nous proposons au mouvement
démocrate avec un diawling un grenelle
de l'air avec l'ensemble des communes
avoisinantes et la ville de paris pour
prendre des engagements en semble
évidemment que c'est facile à paris
c'est pas c'est pas là les gens beaucoup
de voitures à parier on a les métros on
a des transports en commun exceptionnel
mais celui qui est en seine et marne et
qui a une voiture diesel qui polluent
encore un peu aujourd'hui parce que ça
n'allait pas dernier cri parce qu'il a
des revenus qui sont plutôt bas et qui
va travailler tous les jours de l'autre
côté de paris dans les hauts-de-seine
comment fait-il est ce qu'il a une
alternative pour le faire il n'en a pas
et donc moi je crois qu'il faut aussi
penser les choses en mcad alternative
marielle de sarnez était l'invité
politique de france bleu 107 1 on vous
retrouve évidemment sur france bleu
point fr merci d'être venu bonne journée
merci à vous bonne journée à vous